matter of fact that they um they said
juice world had passed I had popped my
last one and that was my last one and
ever since then I never bought one was
that like uh when you saw him him pass
away was that uh Catalyst for you to
stop doing them it was more so a respect
thing because you know the story of how
he passed away he swallowed out on perks
I was kind of like I was like looking at
it like that didn't really make sense
but in the same sense I was like out of
respecter bro I'ma still never pop one
again just in case if that was the case
um world may never know but I know there
was spark you need to stop you guys uh
Matt uh how how was he as a guy I mean I
was cool I had a freestyle on my show
once and I was blown away because he
rapped for like 15 minutes straight yo
that's what it is I feel like that's the
story of juice like it was a [ __ ]
Master Class rapper crazy and like
didn't even do that on his albums really
but like he could wrap circles around
everybody like off the top of his head
man I remember the first tour I went on
and there was a juice World Tour ski
mask slump God and then I was like the
opener to a lot of the shows lots of
mosh Pits on that tour a whole lot of
them
um
first time meeting them the first thing
he said to me was like yo my favorite
gun at kale Tech what's yours and I was
like damn you know what's up for nothing
like I know after that I just kind of
took a liking them to him because I knew
he was different you know I said I told
him I like dracos and then after that we
was just cool and he wrapped for like 30
minutes straight like 30 minutes I was
just mesmerized I was sitting out
looking at him like yo he's not stopping
like he was it was put on another beat
like after he'd already been eight
minutes in on one beat telling him to
replay it keep replaying it over I was
like yo [ __ ] machine that's pretty
historical tour to be a part of man it
was beautiful
um a lot of people I met along until I
think like um cold Bennett met a lot of
people sitting down a great foundation
for myself
um it was a beautiful tour it was
beautiful and then it was crazy um
when it came for me to have my own tour
this year
um I had nle tour in America and I sold
out like 90 of my dates like
congratulations and it was huge for me
because I felt like like juice like and
then I had people that was coming the
tour that was open enough for me and I
was looking at them as like me yeah
hoping like four years y'all have your
own [ __ ] going like you know what I mean
that's dope man then I went to Europe
and Canada all in this same year and I
sold out Europe completely sold out
Canada like 90 of that as well you know
it was just beautiful so I felt like I
felt like the universe was bringing you
know great blessings upon me and like
versus where I was when I was 16 just
looking up